le plus sûr non
parlez moi la main le 6è
deux noms
m
non
chan
[Musique]
celui là il y a juste l'eau déjà les
ailes avis le var et atteindre la fin
je sortis de la garde non de météores un
colis géniez des gens n'est venu il
n'avait pas lu ces messages pour que
gpon le voyeur ma
soyez au rendez-vous de cette rue de la
grange aux loups
faites vite il y avait de quoi
[Musique]
pourquoi ces dernières auraient pillé
des années d'errance il me rome on est
en plein coeur son cri déchire le
silence elle depuis qu'il s'en était
allé longtemps chauvet disparaître ce
vagabond solis par les voilà qu'ils
aimaient leur venue entre une grange aux
loups
je m'en souviens du rendez-vous que j'ai
gravées dans ma mémoire
cette chambre est au fond d'un couloir
et d'une cheminée
j'ai vu quatre mosquées la lumière est
un mois de mai blanche
il porte l habit du dimanche
je n'ai pas posé de questions ac c'est
ton jeu compagne et 11g rien team est
dans le regard
j'ai compris qu'il était trop de fautes
rendez vous rue de la grange où il ne
m'a jamais rappelé
il avait déjà disparu voilà
la connaît l'histoire il était allé voir
et ce fut son dernier voyage et se fait
punir l'image il est voulait amender
mourir serait champion mon sourire mais
lui-même centaine à 10 cents
ils ont la mer rouge dans un genre de
pierre je veux que tarantino à l'ombre
du nord
[Musique]
m
oh
on
[Musique]
je me souviens
bon
[Musique]
oh
le
[Musique]
le petite cantate tupou des loups et
obsédant dumas droite menthe verte ou
une petite cantate comme nous jouions
autrefois ça le jeu l'ajout maladroite
similaires et son dauphin
cette petite contre fort solde au fond
n'était pas si me dois de camps
s'étaient tous et notre court et facile
heureuse au bout de dix doigts
moi j'étais l'homme à l'habit similaires
et sans le dauphin et tu es parti
fragile vert
au delà et jaurès la ville parole
d'enfant je te revois souriante la 6e
finale 1
dix ans range sous toi chante chante
chante la pop au moins similaires et
civils un des six soldats au front
simi le récit minresi sandoa au mon ami
amadou sur massy petit à moi mon dieu
qu'elle est difficile
cette cantate en toi une petite bruine
avec mon coeur pour le fun et mais du
doigt
une petit de payeurs mais sans un signe
de croix keller france dieu le père il
me le par
similar et 6000 à risque ferme d'en haut
c'est bizarre et séminaristes et son
dauphin échanges avec leurs trompettes
de jour en jour un porte-voix
ça te dit quant à dire que nous jouions
autrefois mes anges avec l'ourthe on
fait tout lâche rouge pour toi
cette petite bande
anthony mandler
notre petit que pan
qui monte vers toi cp l'aurès mais ne
réussit sans pouffer
[Musique]
voilà combien de jours on voit combien
de nuits
[Musique]
le continent tu étais parti me disent
toutefois dernier voyage vers les
derniers
il serait de retour le printemps ce
jeune humour se parlent d'amour nous
irons forains arrivent au retard pris et
déambuleront dans les rues de paris
il
reviens de retour
et
[Musique]
c
e
tant pis pour eux
tout le temps perdu
non
on sera plus le printemps s'est enfui
d'où il lors des frappes menées mortes
brûlées
mais lentement
je frissonne jeu tendu
comme leurs ongles je veux cheville
je m n ont ni maman je parle tout bas je
le mal d'amour
je ne manque de tout
oui
ne
en communauté
je sais tu
pourtant tu penses de nous
[Musique]
l'ue met en beauté mais toujours j'ai
beau aimer fais toi j'ai beau aimer
d'amour qui ne m'apprend qu'il revenir
ferait de nous des mets plus venir je
prends le monde émerveillé me répond un
autre soleil
je ne suis pas de sa mort de chagrin
je n'ai pas la vertu à me demain
[Musique]
mais en fut bien nocturne
m
- l'institut
ban ki moon
remarquez
[Musique]
un père d
nous sommes
[Musique]
une
[Applaudissements]
pour une longue dame brune
j'ai tenté une chance au clair de la
lune
quelques couplets
si jamais l'entente un jour elle saura
que c'est une chanson d'amour
elle et moi
je suis d'alp enquête 1 me brune
tu attends
sous la longue dame brune
et je tends faons
en temps normal à lui
ceux ci avaient retour aux guitares de
fortune
if metall qui roma avait prêté sa plume
[Musique]
se tue
heather de fortune
brimeux là
je me suis pris cours 1er en écrivant
les mots qui passait par ma peur
[Musique]
le vent qui rentrent avait prêté sa
plume
de nuit là
la guitare ou de fortune
il est là
et tu te plaît pourquoi
non
en écrivant mon équipe à supporter
comme le font
j'ai habillé latham heureux
dans mes pensées
[Musique]
la mention de voile de brume
de rose et j'ai faits sont les contre ma
peau
pour qu'elle soit bien
le prix
eh bien mon show entre mes mains
habillé d'un voile de brume de rosé
sous la main et à murray
je n'ai pas pensé
en tendance devant lui
je viens vers toi héritant de fortune
it may pour une longue dame brune
j'ai inventé
une chance au clair de la lune
[Musique]
quelques couplets
je sais qu'elle l'entende un jour qui
sait demain
pour que cette chanson d'amour ni ce
bien
bonjour je suis la pomme est brune
dans marché bonjour je suis la dame
brune
roubaix
il
oui
très bien
le manche en lien dans l'abri
entre quatre ans
[Musique]
ah la la
et
nous
[Musique]
du plus loin me reviennent l'ombre de
mes amours anciennes les plus loin du
premier rang des cours du temps des
premiers rennes lors j'avais 15 ans
appelle coeur tout blanc écrit 11 au
genou
ce fut j'étais pour être assez de temps
de re samour de gosse ou les morsures de
l'amour fou du plus loin que je m'en
souvienne
si depuis j'ai toujours peur
ma plus belle histoire d'amour c'est
vous
c'est vrai je ne fus pas ça jouer j'ai
tourné bien des pages
sans les lire blanche puis rien dessus
c'est vrai je ne fais pas
je l'aimais guéri
de passage à peine a vu déjà disparu
mais à travers la vitre on s'était déjà
votre image c'était faux béchard et le
car est nu
enfin le bateau
et poursuivait fournir aux plus folles
histoires de
sur la longue route
il venait
revault sur la longueur groupe
j'allais le
je le vends 2 décembre le jeu lettre aux
coûts et apporter des cendres
c'était pour vous
elle fut long de la route je lève la
roue et le lac qui menait jusqu'à vous
je ne suis pas par jour si ce soir je
vous jure que pour vous je lui fait à
genoux
[Musique]
il en eût fallu bien d'autres que
quelques mauvaises pondre que l'hiver ou
le neige à mon goût pour que je perde
patience
j'ai calmé ma violence
une belle histoire de sebo
et on y verrait d'open de nuit de jour
et personne vous n'étiez jamais au
rendez vous et de vous perdre encourage
soudain me prenais l'arbre à mon dieu
que j'avais besoin de vous que dit on
plus vous en force et d'autres m'ont
tous faire leur le pauvre de
heureusement le loin de vous
oui je loupais fidèles venus des lycées
j'ai pleuré mais là
qui me fut doux ou qu'il me fait douze
premiers sourires de vous il faut une
lame qui venait de vous je pleurais
d'amour
[Musique]
vous souvenez-vous ce fut un soir en
septembre
vous étiez venu m'attendre si même vous
en souvenez vous
vos regards des sourires vous aimez sans
rien dire là que j'ai compris tout à
coup
dès mon voyage
j'ai posé mes bagages
vous étiez venu au rendez vous
je ne
je vous remercie de vue
qu'un bon augure je suis venu
[Musique]
ma plus belle histoire d'amour c'est
vous
[Musique]
bien sûr on n'est pas là pour le voit
devenir
c'est bien joli tout de même de l'amour
l'amour y fleurit quand même à göttingen
benghazi
sa venue histoire de nos rois de france
herman 8h elgar et on a que singer 109
ans
mais les contes de notre enfance il
était une fille moi commencer à
göttingen
bien sûr nous nous avons l'a350
nous avons nos motos de meylan c'est là
mais lhenry même s'il ne peut rien nous
dire ah ils restent là à nous sourire et
nous les comprenons temps même les ans
volonté d'être une gueule
en pis pour ceux qui s'étonnent et que
les autres me pardonne
les enfants aiment à paris quoique thing
heures en fait que jamais de revenir et
le temps ce sont les graines il ya des
champs
göttingen
lens honorer le lendemain il ne faut pas
attendre des heures
[Musique]
ce serait une l'homme pour xing
l'enfant
serais tu
[Musique]
il marche le regard sienne maintenant
moi devant et derrière maison mais si
j'allonge les mains ils me suivent pas à
pas je ne leur échappe pas mes hommes
soit ils sont là non mais qu'attendre et
pendant au moins les regards de venir
rien ne leur a pas venu c'est bon de les
voir tous les six mois si celui-ci est
découpée en forme ou de la nuit de la
luge
quand j'arrive le teint blême mois
devant eux derrière je comprends bien
que les gens s'immolent s'étonne
farid est fini mais marseille toulon lui
[Musique]
il marche avec insolence un petit rien à
sauver les gens mais elle ne m'appelle
pas mal on se sent vraiment qu'ils me
nomment patronne il soumet kamal loi
jamais soumise à leur loi
ceci dit de venir à mes hommes fous
d'amour et de tendresse
mais surtout on fait une forte mais
hommes non vous ne passerez pas ils sont
bien dans quelques fois c'est un joli
toucher pour les mêmes raisons
ils se sont fait sentir dans il pourrait
l'être suhail al gore il me veil comme
moi je l'aimais quelquefois mois
pourrait fournir en est les premiers on
le fera grincer vous des hommes vont se
mettre sans un mot debout autour du
piano mais me dise tendrement patron
[Musique]
c'est fou comme ils sont deux maisons
dans le son du piano noir
aulas
faire leurs bagages on reprend le voyeur
pour qu'ils voient lubie je mets en
fournissant la nuit sur des fonds afin
de souligner ses cibles s ils vont
chasser dans la nuit berger gardez vos
brebis qui ont le plus envie les hommes
mais ils vont coucher leurs fournisseurs
des hommes
et repartent dans la nuit pour toi mais
pas avant de rire quand on profite aux
moeurs avec des fleurs dans les médiums
et là silence une timide baissant les
yeux
en attendant fait je leur valeur ils ont
installé mon lit les sabres ou à l'ombre
d'une algérie mes hommes
je vais m'endormir un nombre qui
creuseront ma tombe pour la longue nuit
pour refonder
en revanche selon les zones ce n'est pas
les coûts de renouvellement continu et
le regard fier je serai là au milieu ou
devant et moins derrière mes bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur le grand paris bio paul s'il est
surtout de paul sarrabère l'hectare coup
j'ai pleuré de rire droite est un autre
plan solaire se porter et des belles
attendait pygmalion assis au pied d'un
chêne souvient de vous aider vous que
des jeunes la femme marienbad la barre à
marienbad
mais où donc est à bout touchant les
probl s'il voit deux marques elles
valent bien loin de marielle 20 séances
étant pas de gang ou le vent qu'il
chantait colère et dans et dans les
premiers les allures règles de l'ue 1
ses lèvres
et moi pauvre des auvents de vos envies
au coeur de volée d'un jeune était fêlée
souvient de vous en 720 la femme bun
morgan balles ou des bouchons des
consommables et moi le mal vient loin
derrière
c'était un grand château par jour et 100
tout profit son esprit d avis que les
ordres les efforts si je combattais leur
sapin est furieuse agréé effet en ces
temps là j'ai eu chaud
je voulais aller j'étais un peu sorcier
que vous l'aimez l'usiné le toit
souvenirs malheureux l'accord amendé
elmer l'apa marienbad ou des îlots de
marquer
bien loin de mariée
mais si vous m'appeliez de 7 ans
prochain pour parler des trois tranches
mais j'ai changé
haché mais je suis comme avant pour me
font laisse peu d enlèvement des folles
dangoumau l'écran de soie noire la no de
diamant ce salaire vos frères en
tranches pour vous faire pour faire de
beaux débats là la remarque n bad
et nous dans vos enfants
non c'est prend la parole
alors aux yeux de chat ne l'a pas à pas
[Musique]
non
bon vent
lapin à marienbad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour qui comment et pourquoi
entre eux qui commandent contre quoi on
est assez de vent violent dangereux
vous venez vous ou allez vous qui êtes
vous qui devriez vous prie de faire
oscille entre eux
[Musique]
pour qui maman dans les pourquoi
philippe aux textes joliment bourgeois
montre quelles étaient les chances
si pour le soleil couchant en et
téléphonie le disais je suis pour les
forêts pro fort carré non enfin il pleut
nous soit de n'importe où mais un enfant
ses fleurs ses rennes enfin venue mais
j'avoue de refuser certains enfants
mâles dominants d'avoir à choisir entre
deux îlots fort c'est abominable avoir
pourrait nominer rire de l'empathie
femmes enfants et combien contre qui
comment et combien en est jeté
[Musique]
le coup de chaud celui perle un sapin en
histoire les patineurs
le courrier pour bref fait rien pour
être avec vous mais c'est dia et pour
une ronde trouvèrent
pour une respiration et pour un souffle
d'abandon ne pourrai jardins fleuris ce
fameux rien à voir ne rien se dire et
faire du mal mais ces données avec une
heure
[Musique]
les riches de dépossession avoir de sa
vérité les riches et de poésie et le
sauveur jouer la transparence ou qu'on
dit nouveaux murs de rire ou l'eau mais
là je mets ça chante pour qui comme un
enfant et pour voir contre qui commet
contre moi pour retrouver le goût de
vivre est là bas un square des
batignolles entre les contrarier votre
personne et construire et pour le
prouver pour une respiration et pour un
souffle de vent dans l'est pour ce genre
et du transport des vivres ou eva finné
mais c'est pas tout seul
oh
[Musique]
et riche de dépossession en avoir la
vérité
ne plus parler d'euphorie si le prix
parle de poésie mais laissée libre et
cela vaut faire jouer la transparence au
fond d'une cour murs des rues où l'on
aurait enfin sa chance des concessions
avancer sans vérité dans toutes les
régions
[Musique]
il veut
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
je me sens bien dans le noir lentement
ses serres déploie la vie voyez deux
mois dans un bruit
en mettant de l'oise 1 français il rit
vous l'avez sont faux brière oiseaux roi
rené en fait un trianon
100 des îles le tout neuf litres en
salle au menu dix ans ont passé mais aux
vives et moi pour mon pays
toutefois comme avant dans les fonds
pour payer retrouver les étoiles l'été
voit le vent en virée dedans pas
vraiment
serra lui à gerland comme avant lui
[Musique]
le
euh moi non
lee daniels
[Musique]
bon
bonjour
[Musique]
mais là je mettais normé
soudain en devenant surgi d'un jour
[Musique]
je vais dormir
en plus ils en ont ils pas surgi des
noirs
[Musique]
le
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]